Is it fresh or is it fake?
Tough to tell right?
Artificial trees aren't what they used to be.
They're more realistic and they're easier to set up.
Well, before you buy,...
...here are some things to think about when you choose your artificial tree.
The material matters.
You can choose shredded PVC,...
...which used to be the main material used for artificial trees.
Not very realistic-looking, but it is easy on the budget.
Or you can choose PE or polyethylene.
PE can be molded to look more like a real tree.
It gives the branches and needles more substance and they're more pliable.
Finally, the choice of material influences the time it takes to set up the tree.
Trees made from shredded PVC do need some shaping,...
...while trees made from PE are basically ready to go right out of the box.
Wanna save even more time?
Choose a pre-lit tree so you can just pop it together and plug it in.
Remember to shop with some measurements in hand.
You need to know the height of the space where you'll place the tree...
...and available width too.
And don't forget to account for a tree topper when you're measuring.